So here's our invariant checker for the class Red-Black tree.
You want to make sure that the root node is black: you can make a mistake,
say, move the subtree up here and all of the sudden the root becomes red.
This assertion will take care of this.
And as you can see here, we're setting up helper functions in order to break down
the invariant into manageable small pieces.
We want to make sure that there are no cycles in the tree.
We want to make sure that pointers to parents are consistent,
that is, if some node points to its parent then it should also be a child of this array parent.
We want to make sure that in both subtrees the number of black nodes is equal.
That's a niiice looong function name, which says it all.
And finally, you want to make sure that red nodes have only black children
and at the same time black nodes only have red children.
Not sure whether we need to make this a separate method.
Some of these checkers are rather trivial, that is one-liners,
others require a traversal of the anti-tree and would typically call themselves recursively.
And now for every single method that change the state, you can now invoke the invariant checker.
You do so at the beginning, you do so at the end,
and when all of your assertions pass, then you can be sure that your Red-Black tree
never ever becomes corrupted.
However, if something goes wrong, it would get the error message at the very moment
you make the Red-Black tree inconsistent.
You will get the precise assertion that failed and you won't implant any time bombs
'cause if the precondition is satisfied and if the postcondition is violated
you know that it is precisely this method--the insert method in this case--
that caused the data invariant to be violated.
This thing about Red-Black trees actually is a sort of a personal thing for me:
ten years ago, when I was a teaching assistant, my professor had the cool idea
to have the students implement Red-Black trees as a programming exercise.
And we as teaching assistants, had the cool idea to come up with a real hard
automated testing for the student assignments, which turned out a disastrous combination
because writing a Red-Black tree is one thing
and writing a Red-Black tree that works is another.
At this time, I did not really know how to debug and neither did my students
and neither did my professor so we as teaching assistants would be sitting with our students
for hours and hours and hours in the night stepping and stepping and stepping
through the program and try to figure out where on earth on the umpteenth insert operation
this particular pointer would finally be moved to this other location, which was a total pain to figure out.
In particular with regular debuggers, we typically step over the whole thing
and then finally lose the moment so you'd have to restart again and restart again.
And if I think about how many hours probably days and weeks
I have lost digging through these data structures whereas with a single invariant checker
I could've found them in minutes I'm still somewhat sorry.